I want to ask --
In all seriousness,
I mean, there is a questio
of when you get up to thos
numbers, when it's 15, 16,
now it's, you know, 21 people,
and you don't have much
of a national base.
You know, why did you
decide to do this?
-The reason I decided to do it
is I think we're at risk
of being the first generatio
of Americans
to leave less opportunity,
not more,
to the people coming after us.
That's how I feel
about our generation.
We've had 40 years
when 90% of the American peopl
haven't seen a pay raise.
We have no economic mobility
in this country at all anymore
And I think we really
have to restore integrity
to this government of ours
This is an exercise
in self-government.
It's not someone else's
government.
And the Freedom Caucus and
Ted Cruz and now Donald Trum
have done a good job
of separating, you know,
this government
from the American people.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And it -- it --
You know, it may be, and I think
it is, in many ways corrup
and bankrupt and obsolete,
all of which are invitations
for us to fix it.
You can't just leave it alone.
This is how we make decisions.
Other countries around the world
who are not inconvenienced
by our form of democracy,
like China, don't have to wait
for us to get our act together
So, you know, you think
about the six months we spen
screwing around with
Donald Trump
and the wall that Mexico
was supposed to pay for.
During that period of time
China landed somebody
on the dark side of the moon
They're building 3,000 miles
of fiber-optic cable
connecting Latin America
with Africa, with China.
And we've spent $5 trillio
since 2001
on tax cuts for rich peopl
and $5.6 trillion
in the Middle East.
That's $11 or $12
or $13 trillion
that we could have investe
in America,
invested in the American peopl
to drive our economy
for everybody,
and we might as well have lit it
on fire, is my position,
and I think
we need to change it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Do you have -- You know,
as people sort of say, you know,
I think to some degree,
it's like,
oh, Cory Booker, you know,
he's making his main
issue gun control.
You know, Bernie's
medicare for all.
Klobuchar seems to be,
you know, infrastructure.
Kamala, you know, teacher pay.
Is there a Michael Bennet issu
right now
that you're hanging on?
-Well, I actually do think tha
this restoring economic growth
reaches everybody in America
It really is the job
that we have to do,
because the democracy
will not survive
with this level
of income inequality.
It won't.
We know that from history.
And our income inequality toda
is the highest it's been
in 100 years.
The lack of economic mobilit
I described earlier.
So I think there are many things
we need to do. That's one.
We've got to deal
with climate change.
with immigration.
We've got to deal
with infrastructure.
As somebody who was a former
school superintendent,
we need to do a hell of a lo
better job than we're doin
educating people in this country
at every single level.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And so -- And finally
what I'd say about this is w
have to govern ourselves again
We have to learn how to do it.
That's not just a Trump problem.
We were screwed up
before he got there.
When I asked people who vote
for Donald Trump in my state
"Why did you vote for him?
almost always they say, "W
wanted to blow the place up.
And so I say to them,
"Congratulations.
You achieved
what you wanted to do,
but what are we
going to do now?"
And, you know, when I thin
about how much wasted time
there's been in the Senate the
10 years that I've been there,
the waste of opportunity for
the next generation of Americans
and the generation after that --
When this country was founded,
it was not founded
on the expectation that
we would agree with each other
It was founded
on the expectation
that we would disagree
with each other.
That was the whole point
of living in a republic...
or now what we call a democracy.
And we've got to get back to a
place where we're disagreein
but using that disagreemen
to fashion more durable
and more imaginative solutions
than any king or tyrant coul
ever think of themselves.
And that's going to require
lot more out of us as citizens
and a much higher expectatio
of what our elected leadership
should look like in D.C.
-You mentioned
imaginative solutions.
I do want to bring it back
to Colorado before we go.
Is it true that magic mushroom
are going to be legal
in Colorado?
-Yeah. I don't know what ha-
I think that our voters
just voted to --
Yeah, in Denver to do that
and I don't know.
I think they might have though
that we were out of marijuan
all of a sudden.
-Yeah. Or they're worried
they're gonna be.
-And, by the way, we're no
out of marijuana in Colorado
-Well, that's what it says
on the state flag now, right
-Exactly.
-Thanks so much for being here
-Thanks for having me.
-Best of luck.
-Senator Michael Bennet,
everybody.